RAY: Hello, everyone.
Thank you so much for
joining us this afternoon.
I hope you guys didn't have to
wait too long in the hot sun,
although secretly I
was hoping that there'd
be a long line for our talk.
My name is Ray.
I'm a product manager on
the Android media team,
and I'm responsible
for Android Pro Audio.
Android Pro Audio
is an initiative
that we launched last
year to bring together
device makers, silicon
partners, and Android engineers
to provide a true professional
performance audio platform
for Android app developers.
This means being
able to write apps
that use MIDI,
high-resolution input
and output, USB digital
audio, floating point,
audio processing and all
of that with a round trip
latency of less than
20 milliseconds.
Now when we announced
this initiative,
we knew it was going to
be a multi-year effort
with a lot of moving parts,
some out of our control.
But even though it's
been only a year,
we've actually seen some
really exciting developments
from our hardware and
software partners.
And so with that, I'd like to
introduce you to Dan to show
some really cool audio apps.
DAN GALPIN: All right.
Thank you very much.
I'm Dan Galpin.
I'm a developer advocate and
I work with a lot of partners
to help build great audio
experiences on Android.
And I wanted to first do a call
out to my colleague Don Turner.
He couldn't be here today.
So this is Don
"Turntable" Turner
as a young guy working
on his Pro Audio stuff.
And then, of course, this
is what his desk actually
looks like today.
It's a little neater.
But there is a lot of passion
in this team about Pro Audio.
And I just want to make it
clear, every single one of us
up here is a musician.
Every single one
of us up here cares
passionately about what we do.
All right, it's not
that mind-blowing,
but it's still pretty darn cool.
So let me get started
with the first demo.
This is on a Nexus 9,
and we're running DRC.
And a lot of people seen
apps like this-- OK,
if we can have the audio
output, tell me that's working.
All right.
OK, that's pretty cool.
We got some nice low bass here.
But what's really
neat about this
is in addition to
this low bass, I've
also got this keyboard
plugged in here.
And what I can do is I
can do these high patches
at the same time,
and this is taking
advantage of a feature we added
in Android M to do proper MIDI.
And what's really cool about
this is in addition to actually
being able to do MIDI
output like this is doing,
you'll also see MIDI input.
And this device can
actually reconfigure
itself to act as a
MIDI audio interface.
You can plug this into
a PC and it actually
looks just like a MIDI device.
And this is cool
because DRC actually
can work as a MIDI synthesizer
for your desktop workstation,
which is awesome.
And we actually have an example
of this over in the Pro Audio
sandbox for all of you
guys that are here.
All right, so the next demo,
I'm going to pull this out.
The next demo I'm
going to show off
is something very, very cool.
And this is the
one I really wish
Don could have been
here for, because Don
is like an amazing, amazing DJ.
I, on the other hand, am
like super rank amateur.
But we're going
to show edjing app
and, we're going to show this
really awesome device, which
has powered itself off.
Let me switch this off again.
Hold on, give me
like a moment here.
This is what's great.
You know getting live demos
when I'm like, come on.
Come on.
Work, work, work.
Yes, all right,
so-- now I've got
to do this all from scratch.
This was all set up
for you guys beforehand
so there'd be none of this
kind of stuff going on,
but that's what's great
about doing this stuff live.
So we can hear the
audio from that.
And this is really cool.
It's showing off really,
really cool low latency
Bluetooth, along with
low latency audio.
And so I can go and mix
between these two tracks.
And that's what DJs do.
They create rhythmic
patterns by going
between two different
tracks like this,
and you see how
responsive this app is.
Of course, I can also do
the stuff like scratch
against the record, as well.
So that is an example of doing
really cool Pro Audio work DJ
style here on Android.
I'm going to unplug this.
I'm going to show one
more app on this device,
though, so we can
keep this going.
And this app really
needs no introduction.
All I have to say is thanks
to our partners here at Korg,
we're doing K Oscillator
here on Android.
Really, really awesome.
Again, super thank you
to them for the support
of Android Pro Audio.
OK, I've got one last demo.
One last demo to
show you guys here.
And last but certainly,
certainly not least,
here we are.
OK, it should be all
plugged in and connected.
All right, so this is the
noise synthesizer from ROLI.
And this is cool.
You're seeing a
virtual seaboard rise,
which is an amazing instrument.
If you're here at
I/O you can actually
check one out in our Pro Audio
sandbox and get to play on it
yourself with this
amazing multi-touch panel.
What's really cool is that
it's not just a keyboard,
but I can move up and down
to get different effects.
I can also slide across
here to do pitch bending.
And of course,
fully multi-touch,
fully multi-channel.
And it's really, really powerful
what you can do with this.
You can create
almost any instrument
with incredible
amounts of expression.
And this is all running on
the Juice platform, which
has been updated so that anyone
can build amazing Pro Audio
apps with really, really
low latency audio.
So a big shout-out to
our partners and friends
over at ROLI for putting
this together for us.
And again, there's some
amazing, amazing people.
If you go onto
YouTube, just watch
what people do with the C board,
watch people do with noise.
It's absolutely,
absolutely incredible.
So that's the kind
of stuff we're doing.
Really low latency audio, really
professional applications.
All right, you can go
back to the slides now.
All right, so--
RAY: So I know I've
seen this in rehearsal,
but that was super impressive
every time I see it.
Thank you so much.
And again, thank you to our
partners, ROLI, edjing, DRC,
by Imaginando.
Thank you so much.
DAN GALPIN: So thanks, Ray.
I hope you agree.
These are some
awesome experiences.
Now, developing apps
like this isn't easy
and our partners have run into
many problems along the way.
So I'd like to
share with you some
of the most common
problems they encounter
and the solutions,
so you don't have
to go through the
same level of pain
when you're developing
your audio apps.
Now, to make this
more interesting-- we
saw a preview of
this-- I'm going
to put some code on
the screen, and I
want you to see if
you can figure out
what the problem is with this
code?
OK, does anyone--
come on, I want hands.
What's the problem
with this code?
Anyone?
OK, yes.
AUDIENCE: So it has
a fixed sample rate--
DAN GALPIN: It has a
fixed sample rate, yes.
OK.
That is excellent.
Thank you.
You can tell we've got people
doing Pro Audio out here.
It's fixed, and
that's a problem,
because every Android device
has a preferred rate that
is set by the system.
And it's usually
not 44.1 kilohertz.
So not only is this
a fixed sample rate,
but it's usually going
to be the wrong one.
And if that happens, your audio
is going to be on a re-sampler.
And so it's not going
to be able to go
through the fast path,
which means you're not going
to get the lowest latency.
So how do we solve this?
We can use the AudioManager API
and query for the device audio
property and pass
that over to OpenSL.
Yes, and I know what you're
saying, and being like,
wait, I'm having to use JNI.
Like, what?
Look, this is a very
small amount of JNI.
It's very, very little effort.
And honestly, this is an
enormous performance gain.
And it's really pretty simple.
So once again, this is how
you get the native sample
rate for the device.
OK.
Another problem is I'm
getting high audio latency
on every single device.
Why would this happen?
All right, so tell me
what's wrong with this code.
This one's actually
pretty straightforward.
Anyone?
Why do I always
see the same hands?
RAY: There's another
one back there.
DAN GALPIN: No, there is.
There is.
OK.
Shout it out.
AUDIENCE: It has
too much buffer.
DAN GALPIN: It's got
too big of a buffer.
It's got too much buffer.
Yes.
We should have, like,
parting gifts for this.
This is awesome.
OK.
So yes, that's
exactly the problem.
Not only that it's a fixed size.
So it's way too large for low
latency output at 4,000 frames.
We're talking 83 milliseconds.
Now back in the old
days of Android, back
when I first started
ages ago, that actually
wasn't that big of a buffer.
But today, our devices
are way faster than that.
So we're talking about
83 milliseconds of just
in this buffer.
So you're not going to get super
low latency audio that way.
So what's the solution?
Of course what we want to do is
go back and ask AudioManager,
say, what is the best buffer
size we should be using?
What's the optimal one?
And the device will tell us.
And then if you use that
buffer size in your OpenSL ES
callbacks, like this, you're
going to get the fast mixer,
you're going to get the best
audio playback in your apps.
OK, well, this doesn't
solve all of your problems,
because what happens
if you actually
are doing this cool
synthesizer that you wrote
and you're hearing glitches,
but you notice, like,
wait, I tap the screen
and my glitches go away?
OK, so what you're seeing
here is Android trying
to do stuff about battery life.
OK?
And what happens is, if you're
not touching the screen,
Android goes, well, you're
not doing anything important.
No one's interacting with me.
And so it scales back the CPU.
And this results
in late callbacks,
because you aren't able
to do as many work cycles.
This is actually something we
call the interactive scheduler
at work actually trying
to help you save battery.
Except you really don't want
that, because you really want
cool audio playback.
So there is actually a way
to sort of work around this.
And it's kind of a hack
trick horrible thing
that we'll have a better
solution for very soon.
But create a workaround.
I like that.
Yeah.
So this is what happens.
So the system decides
to throttle the CPU
based on how often the user
is touching the screen.
So what we can do is
we send fake touches
and convince it that the
screen is still being touched.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
DAN GALPIN: I know.
Here are the groans
from the aud-- hey,
hey, look, don't shoot
the messenger, OK?
I mean-- but no, this--
so now Android will go,
OK, the screen is
constantly being touched.
It thinks that it's
in interactive mode.
And this is really important
if you're doing something
like input, or if
you're using-- even
if you're doing, like, a VR
app and you're using sensors.
Like, you're not
touching the screen.
Android might say,
well, I shouldn't
be doing anything now.
But so this does
actually, actually work.
It convinces Android the
screen is being touched.
And seriously, like, yeah, we're
going to do something better.
OK.
Last problem is the
one I hear the most.
You know, it's, we spend
a lot of time debugging.
We get audio glitches
and crackles.
They've done all the
other things right.
And for example, we've
got an app that's
running on a device with
an 192-frame sized buffer,
and it's a sample rate
of 48 kilohertz, which
means you're going
to get callbacks
every four milliseconds.
And in those four
milliseconds, you
have to generate 192
frames of audio data.
And if you don't, you're
going to get a glitch.
But the problem is that,
in fact, the cause of it
is that you're not always
able to supply it in time.
And the reason-- the
real question is why?
Why was your app not
always able to actually
supply this data in time?
And there are two
possible causes.
One of them is you
might be blocking,
or you might be doing too
much work in the callback.
And let's take a quick look
at some causes of those.
So first thing you want to
do is check for any blocks
in the audio callback.
This means going through your
code and just analyzing it.
You know, examining it
and checking for things
like waiting on other threads.
JNI calls, which
basically is kind
of like waiting
on other threads,
because it adds synchronization
which could block you.
Memory allocations.
Believe it or not,
memory allocations
actually can block you.
Not shocking.
System calls also can block.
And of course, you
can use Systrace
with audio, sched, and freq, How
many people here use Systrace?
Raise hands.
That is not nearly enough.
More people should use Systrace.
It is an awesome, awesome tool.
If you want to learn more
about using Systrace,
you come to my session, or come
online for tomorrow at 9:00
AM over in Ursa Minor OK.
And I'll be talking
about Systrace.
Once you're
eliminated any blocks,
you need to figure out how
much work you're doing.
And you can do this
using clock_gettime,
as this gives you
nanosecond accuracy.
And logging inside the
callback is problematic,
so you want to keep
that to a minimum.
And a trick you can use is to
keep a count of the callbacks,
and we log one every
x number of calls.
And there's even better tricks,
like keeping a ring buffer.
Or you can use the Trace command
with Systrace, which is pretty
cool, to create trace segments.
There's a native API
we added in M for that,
so it doesn't even force a
JNI call, which is great.
And then the other thing
that can drastically
affect your performance is
your build configuration.
Always make sure that you do
not debug your debug build.
I know this doesn't
make sense, but when
you're doing
performance debugging,
you always want to make
sure you're actually
looking at your release
build, because it's
going to be a lot faster.
We take out a lot of things.
Also make sure to check
your compiler flags.
You know, hardware
float and neon
can make a massive,
massive difference.
Please check out our
high-performance audio website
where we publish the flags
that we actually use as a team.
So make sure the compiler
is actually generating
what you think it is.
Use, like, WA and ASLH to
dump annotated assembly
if you're not sure.
And this is really great.
If you've ever wanted to
learn what compilers do
and just how great they can be,
and sometimes how not great,
take a look at the
assembly that's generated.
It's very, very eye-opening.
OK, and this is kind of the
hardest and most painful
one for me.
Don't use more than 20%
of your callback budget
to generate data.
And so what this means
is that if you're
seeing you're taking more than
about a quarter of that time,
what you should do is
try to scale back things.
Scale back effects, scale
back the amount of polyphony,
because the chances are
you're going to get a glitch.
And or even worse, get a
whole bunch of glitches.
Or maybe the device
will even heat up.
So giving your-- by trying
to take only about 20% to 25%
of that time, you really,
really radically reduce
the chances of glitching.
And ultimately, we want
to make this better.
And we're working
to increase this
both with bug fixes in N,
which Glen will talk about,
and by working closely
with our Silicon partners.
But for now, especially on
older devices-- and we're
talking about current
Android-- sticking to this rule
will give you the best ability
on a wide range of devices.
So that's about all the war
stories I have time for today.
But you can read more
about all of this
and keep up with any new
developments on the Android Pro
Audio webpage.
All right.
[APPLAUSE]
RAY: So as you
can see, it really
is possible to write a
great professional audio app
on Android.
Dan, thank you for all the
tips, the pitfalls to avoid,
and the best practices.
Thank you for that.
DAN GALPIN: All right.
RAY: And of course,
it should not
be that difficult to make
a great Android audio app.
So we're not going
to be happy until we
have an easy-to-use API
and an audio platform that
can guarantee consistent,
predictable performance.
And that's also
something that's not
just available in a few devices,
but on a myriad of devices.
So we're a little ways off from
finishing our Android ProAudio
story, but we've done
some really important work
this year.
And to give you a
progress report,
I want to introduce you to Glen
"Latency Crusher" [? Castin. ?]
[APPLAUSE]
[? GLEN CASTIN: ?] I like
that name, "Latency Pressure."
It's much better than
my other nickname, which
is Glitch [? Castin. ?] It
was really painful for me
to see Dan talking
about glitches,
because I spend a lot of my
time thinking about glitches
and listening to them.
Anyway.
So for me, I really
believe that creativity
should be for everyone,
that everyone should
feel empowered to be creative.
And we all deserve it.
It shouldn't just
be for a select few.
And I believe that there's
billions of people out there,
including Android users, who
should be able to be creative.
In my family, we're musicians.
Four of us play
piano, including me.
And I'd like to introduce to
you my son, rap master Raden--
Aiden.
He likes to create music, too.
He plays acoustic piano, and
also electronic keyboards
and microphone.
Unfortunately, he doesn't
play music on Android.
Not yet.
And this gives me
such a pain, even more
than hearing glitches.
And the reason is
because Android just
hasn't had the consistent
level of high performance
that creative audio
applications need.
And Aiden's not satisfied,
and other musicians
haven't been ready yet-- or
haven't been satisfied yet,
either.
Creative audio applications
require a lot of CPU.
They require it consistently.
They need to run every
few milliseconds.
This is a pro level
of performance.
And that's why we
call it ProAudio.
The pro is for the pro
level of performance,
not for who happens
to be using it.
We believe that ProAudio,
again, is for everyone.
That's where Android comes in.
That's our strength.
One of our strengths
is being able to be
accessible to many, many people.
The openness, the wide range of
form factors and price points.
My work mission is to
reduce audio latency,
to improve
performance, to reduce
glitches, things like that.
We introduced the ProAudio
program overall a year ago,
but actually, I've been
working with my colleagues
for over three years now,
initially on latency.
In 2013 at I/O, we announced
some major reductions
in output latency, along
with my colleagues.
And then the next year,
we announced reductions
in input latency.
The following years, we
talked about USB audio,
which enables really
high-quality audio interfaces.
And we also introduced MIDI,
which is what makes music tick.
That's my slogan.
One thing we found, though, was
that features were not enough,
that we had to have
this consistent level
of performance.
And both our app
developers and our users
needed a way that
they could tell really
easily whether a
device was going
to be capable of that
level of performance
and have all the
features they needed.
So we introduced last
year this thing that we
call the ProAudio feature flag.
It brings together
all the key things
that you need for pro
level of performance--
low latency, MIDI, USB,
the 24-bit data path.
And I'm probably
missing something else,
but it has basically
all the core elements.
It gives us something to
shoot for-- us personally,
and the Android framework team.
And it also gives our OEM
partners and our Silicon
partners something that
they can shoot for.
I mentioned that one
of Android's strengths
is the diversity
of our ecosystem.
We have a large number of
different form factors,
different price points,
and things like that.
And for Android, it's not
realistic, at this point,
to expect that we can
get Android ProAudio
performance everywhere.
And we acknowledge that
with the ProAudio flag.
So now we have something
to shoot for, something
to differentiate.
And certainly, yes, I would
like to have more and more
devices support that.
But initially, it's
our first step.
And at the beginning, we only
had a few devices in the Nexus
family that claimed the ProAudio
flag, but things are changing.
I see hope now for additional
devices from other OEMs,
from other Silicon makers, that
are also going to be supporting
the ProAudio flag.
So please stay tuned for that.
So I mentioned earlier that
in one of my-- my main day job
is getting rid of glitches
and decreasing latency.
It turns out that we can't do
that all just in the framework.
Certainly part of it is
in the portable framework,
but a lot of it has to do with
the device-dependent code.
So I work really
closely with partners.
These include partners
within the-- fellow Googlers
in the Android framework, and
kernel teams and performance
teams, but also
external partners.
Device OEMs, Silicon makers,
people like such as that.
There's one partner that I've
been working with in particular
that I want to mention now.
He's a fellow Googler.
He works in the Chrome OS team.
And he's really helped us
to investigate and challenge
some of the
assumptions that we've
been making about latency.
Let me give an example
of one assumption
that I used to make that
was totally incorrect.
People would say, oh, your
round-trip latency is whatever.
You know, 20
milliseconds or whatever.
What's the output latency?
And I would say, well, I don't
know, but let's call it a half.
Or maybe it's a little
more than a half.
Well, that's not good enough.
And I'd like to introduce Mark.
He's a physicist by training,
and he cares about numbers
and getting them right.
And even better than that,
he works with lasers.
MARK: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi.
My name is Mark.
I work on the Chrome
OS touch team,
and we care a lot about latency.
And I'm guessing a
lot of you do, too.
Now, it's not only latency.
There are a bunch
of different ways
an application can interact
with the physical world.
And all of the interaction
channels listed here
have a typical latency
of milliseconds or tens
of milliseconds.
Now, timing physical events
with millisecond accuracy
is not rocket science.
But when you're
trying to time them
relative to events that
happen inside the CPU,
it gets pretty messy.
It looks something like this.
And then when you try
to touch the device
and, like, use the touchscreen
with all those probes sticking
out of the guts of the phone,
it gets very frustrating.
I tried it.
That's one of the reasons that
the numbers we usually see
are round-trip latencies.
I'll be using [INAUDIBLE]
application as an example here.
My plan of event looks
something like this.
So the round-trip
latency, in this case,
is the time from the moment
somebody touches the screen
and until sounds comes out.
But the subsystems invoked
in such a round-trip
represent a bunch of different
engineering teams, often spread
across different companies.
And if there is a bug, who
should be looking for it?
Blame wars are no fun.
And as a physicist,
I love-- I have
a little obsession with good
measurement instruments.
And for the last
several months, I
have-- I was lucky
to work on building
one that does exactly
the kind of measurements
that we are looking for.
The basic idea is that we use
a device that synchronizes
clocks with a phone.
And then we can
separately measure
the time that passes from the
moment we touch the screen
and until the app got the event.
And in the other
direction, from the moment
that app initiated some output
and some visible or audible
change has been produced.
We called it the
WALT latency timer.
Now, this is a very early
prototype in AudioSetup,
but it's fairly simple.
This is a more
recent device that
can measure latency on
most of the channels
that I've mentioned earlier.
The good news is that it can
work without the need to modify
the device, or even route it.
And we have recently
open-sourced this project.
It's now all on GitHub.
And WALT has produced some
interesting results for Android
audio, and for touch, as well.
Back to Glen.
[? GLEN CASTIN: ?]
So one thing here--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Mark.
One thing here that
shocked me was seeing
that the audio output latency
here was 13 and the input
was five.
You know, I'd been telling
people incorrectly,
oh, just guess half and half.
Well, I was totally wrong.
When you think about
it, it makes more sense.
It has to do with
the number of buffers
and where they are in the
pipeline and things like that.
But it just shows
you how important
it is to actually measure
things, and not just guess.
So together, working in
the Android framework team
together with our partners in
the kernel team, performance
team, our Silicon
partners, our OEM partners,
we've made a lot of progress in
reducing latency and improving
performance.
I want to now turn the
subject to what we're
doing-- what we've just
been working on just
the last few months so you have
sort of a feeling of what we're
up to right now.
And I'll talk about what's
going on in the N release.
First of all, I've made a
lot of mistakes in my career.
I'm happy to admit that.
One of them was I was
so aggressive at trying
to reduce latency that
I took some shortcuts
and cut some corners that
have, in retrospect, turned out
to be not advisable.
One of those was, on the output
side in the device driver,
we've always had
double buffering.
And there's some very
good reasons for that.
But on the app level, we were
encouraging app developers
to do single buffering in the
application, with the rationale
being that the app could
provide the data immediately
and everything would be OK.
That works fine for apps
that create sine waves.
But fortunately-- or
unfortunately, those
are not real ProAudio apps.
Real ProAudio apps,
such as the ones
that you saw Dan demo earlier,
use a huge amount of CPU.
And they would like to
use way more than 20%.
And to do that,
and do it reliably
without glitching, even
under stressful conditions,
you need to have double
buffering in the application
level.
So I'm happy to announce
that in N, we're finally
enabling double,
or even further,
buffering in the
application level
for those apps that need it.
And with an accompanying very
slight increase in latency,
of course.
But it's usually not important.
Then the other thing
I want to mention
is, for those of you
who love the SGK,
the SGK is still there.
And we've improved the audio
latency on the audio track
APIs, too, so that
you can take advantage
of some of the
improvements we've been
making in latency there, too.
You've heard at both the
keynote and lots of sessions
this week about our VR effort.
And VR is very focused on
performance, especially
predictable performance.
It turns out that
VR is, by nature,
a real-time kind of application,
very similar to ProAudio.
And their needs are
very similar to ours.
So we've been
working very closely
with VR and the
performance teams.
Right now, the
features that you've
heard about with VR, such
as sustained performance
mode, those are only
available for VR as of now.
However, we are
working together,
and I really hope to be able to
bring those kind of performance
guarantees to other vertical
domains, such as ProAudio
and any other use
cases like that.
As long as we're
talking about VR,
I wanted to mention there's
a VR session tomorrow
morning at 9:00 AM.
I hope you can attend.
One of my colleagues is
presenting on VR audio.
And also, we also have
another presentation
by Dan tomorrow morning
also, competing with that,
on the NDK.
So both should be
of interest to you,
and hopefully you
can split yourselves
to go to both sessions.
OK.
So here again is the website
for all things audio,
for all things ProAudio.
It's
bit.ly/high-performance-audio.
If you don't remember any other
URL, please remember that one.
So although we have been making
progress over the last three
years, I do want to acknowledge
that we're not done yet.
And we certainly have a
lot more work left ahead
of us, and some of which I
know about, some of which
I can't predict yet, because
we haven't hit them yet.
What I will share
with you is what
we're working on right
now that we know about.
And I'm acknowledging that,
yes, these are problems.
And the good thing, though,
is, despite these problems,
it is possible to get
real work done on Android,
as you've seen these
four apps earlier.
The first thing is more
predictable CPU scheduling
and CPU bandwidth so that
you don't need tricks
like the fake touch.
And also so that you can use
more than 20% of the CPU.
The next is our API.
We recognize that open
SLES is a hard-to-use API.
It requires a lot
of boilerplate code.
And just saying open
SLES is awkward.
I want a simpler name.
So we're listening
to developers.
And I can't make any promises
yet about what it will be
or what it will look like, but
we are working on a new API.
And don't worry if
you love open SLES.
It will still be there.
Finally, round-trip latency.
Currently, our goal
for the ProAudio flag
is 20 milliseconds.
And that is good for
many, many applications,
especially applications that
only do output-only processing,
because then they don't--
their latency is only a portion
of this.
However, there are applications
such as guitar processing,
voice processing,
that can benefit
from even lower latency.
So we are working towards that
magic 10-millisecond round-trip
latency figure.
And I want to achieve that
without causing power problems.
It turns out, in
the lab, we have
hit 10 millisecond round-trip,
but it used too much power.
And so it's not really
ready for release yet.
So I won't be done
with this effort
until Aiden is happy
being creative on Android,
and until all of you are happy
being creative on Android.
Thank you for coming today.
[APPLAUSE]
At this point, I want to
switch to some acknowledgments.
You already heard some
acknowledgements from Dan
about our app partners, a few
of whom are in the room today.
So look for them later on.
For me personally, though,
the people that I work with
most closely are F
and F F And I want
to acknowledge a few of
them by name, although I've
worked with many of them.
First of all,
Qualcomm has really
worked hard to reduce the audio
latency in their signal path,
especially in the DSP.
They've been optimizing
that recently.
Another company I'd like
to acknowledge is NVIDIA.
They've been
focusing on improving
performance and reliability
and stability of scheduling
and task wake-up.
I'm really thrilled to announce
that the demos that you saw
today, at least
one of the demos,
was done on the NVIDIA
Shield K1, and using an early
build of Android that supports
Android ProAudio flag.
And for more information,
please check out these URLs.
NVIDIA will be happy
to-- if you sign up
for their-- to let you download
over OTA a special developer
preview of their
Android ProAudio access.
And if you have questions
about that later on,
we have people in the audience.
We have [INAUDIBLE]-- thank
you, [INAUDIBLE]-- and Bill,
who can also answer your
questions about Android
ProAudio on NVIDIA.
There's one company,
though, that I
want to acknowledge that I
work with even more than-- I
want to give them very
special thank you.
And that's Samsung Mobile.
The reason is is that we're kind
of late to the ProAudio party.
We started thinking
about it a few years ago,
but it turns out
Samsung Mobile has
been-- has had that on their
radar for many, many years.
They saw a real gap
in Android compared
to our competitor platforms,
and they started working on it.
And over the last
few years, they've
been working on the
Samsung ProAudio SDK,
evolving it, coming out
with multiple releases,
and along with accompanying apps
that work well on the ProAudio
SDK.
So I want to acknowledge
Samsung Mobile and invite both
[? Tamin ?] [? Cho ?] and Johnny
[? Zhou ?] up to the stage.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Do you have a mic?
Thank you.
Yeah, OK.
[? JOHNNY ZHOU: Hello. ?] My
name is Johnny [? Zhou. ?]
I'm product owner of
Samsung Professional Audio
and SoundCamp.
I really appreciate Glen and
Ray inviting us on this stage.
As you saw in this
session, Android ProAudio
has great potential
and opportunities
for Android developers.
And I believe it will
be great-- even greater
with Samsung Professional
Audio and its collaboration
with Android ProAudio.
Our lead engineer,
[? Tamin Cho, ?]
will give you more
details about it.
[APPLAUSE]
[? TAMIN CHO: Hi. ?]
Samsung Professional Audio--
also called SAPA for short--
is Samsung's own professional
audio framework.
It was first released in 2013,
and it has two major features.
Of course, the first one
is the low latency audio.
The first version showed the
60-millisecond round-trip
latency on Galaxy Note 2.3.
And the second one is
the interapplication
of their routing, which allows
the streaming audio and MIDI
between the current
applications.
Yes.
Lots more details about the
interapplication audio routing.
So here is an audio
application you made.
And you want to add some
effects to the sound.
Then you have to
build every effects
into the same
application, or using SAPA
you can connect your app
to other effects apps.
You can connect as
many apps you want,
depending on the CPU in whatever
form, in serial and parallel,
with no additional delay.
SAPA's interapplication
audio routing
is based on the well-known
JACK audio connection kit.
So if you're familiar
with the JACK [INAUDIBLE],
then you just say gotcha.
So with this, even you
can build a PC like a DAWF
so you can load multiple
plug-in instruments and effects,
run them simultaneously,
and mix the sounds.
It's highly extensible.
And Samsung also provide
the own DWF, which
is a plug-in architecture.
So you just make a
plug-in and use that.
SAPA-- in order to achieve the
low latencies, SAPA actually--
we made SAPA independent
from the audio-- Android
audio system.
So this why SAPA is only
available on Samsung devices.
But within this year, SAPA
is running on the Android
audio system because, thanks
to the Android ProAudio,
the low latency is available
on Android audio system.
That means SAPA is also
available on known Samsung
devices.
So Sam--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So Samsung decided for
the next flagship device,
our next flagship device, we
going to support the Android
[? ProAudio ?] {} hardware flag.
Thank you.
And if you need
more information,
please refer to the URL here.
And send the questions
to sapa@samsung.com.
And if you have any urgent
question, ask me or Johnny.
[? GLEN CASTIN: ?] Thank you
so much for coming today.
We look forward to seeing
you at the demo booth, too.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]